this is a special day for Steph Cara
deal over
she's been fattening her only Pig for a
year primacy we make sausage we make ham
and a few other things and that feeds us
for a year all her male relatives have
come to Girona a village in eastern
Bulgaria the butcher is a neighbor to
mark the occasion there's a glass of
spirits with breakfast its rakia
distilled by Steph cos husband total for
the rowdy laughs this is supposed to be
a day of celebration but there's
something bothering stefka the NATO
maneuvers taking place in the mountains
nearby they scare me
they really do Russia is not a weak
power it's strong but the presence of
American forces is supposed to give
Bulgarians a feeling of security
Joey Donato is here to protect Bulgarian
slike stefka the 24 year old US Marine
Corps sergeant is part of a tank unit at
the novo cell oat reigning grand this is
also a special day for him he's taking
part in NATO field training exercises
with Bulgarian troops they've been
training for it for more than two months
we have a great training area that it
allows us to move with around with our
tanks as well as Bulgarian mechanized
units and it's a wide enough space so we
can do it together instead of one tank
at a time or a few tanks at a time he
and the other infantry Marines have been
here since August more American combat
tanks arrived as reinforcements a few
days ago the NATO mission here is
open-ended no the tanks are staying here
and they'll be will be replaced but the
tanks are staying the last time foreign
combat tanks were permanently stationed
on Bulgarian soil was more than 70 years
ago when the Soviet Union occupied the
country in the Second World War
what's changed now is the Russian
annexation of Crimea NATO aims to
prevent similar moves in neighboring
countries this particular training
exercise is part of this overall effort
to send a strong signal of preparedness
readiness and resolve in the face of the
challenges that we face on a nice turn
flank but also in a south
the manoeuvre scenario today reflects
that aim units are training how to repel
an attempted invasion it's this kind of
saber rattling that dismayed stefka I
like the Russians they're Christians
like us we lived under the Turkish yoke
for 500 years
the Russians liberated us and that's
reason enough to like them many
Bulgarians would agree with her Russia
and Bulgaria share many linguistic and
cultural similarities it's no accident
that all the dishes staff guys preparing
are also part of Russian cuisine the
historical ties to Russia are also
apparent in Bulgari's military almost
all the equipment joie de Nardo's
bulgarian partners use like these
armored personnel carriers this Soviet
made as we see it on pictures and we
learn about them so it's it was it's
interesting to actually see him in
person and actually train with the
people that work on them before they
operate them
the mess hall serves only American
cuisine the basis television shows
American sports events Joey Delgado sees
little of life off the base yes some off
time here on base but you do have an
option to go out in town on the weekends
but he rarely takes the opportunity the
military base is a familiar environment
and many US soldiers feel uneasy given
the open dislike of the NATO maneuvers
among the surrounding community back in
Giovanna Steph gained her family feel
the same way the people gathered here
say the maneuvers are an unnecessary
provocation for the Russians only the
youngest one disagrees he's the same age
as Joey the Marine Sergeant my
generation has shifted its focus to
other countries England for example
Russia's fallen more by the wayside he
may be the only one at the table who
isn't worried about the NATO forces in
the area but Steph quz grandson is still
in the minority in Bulgaria